Troopers' Memorial is an important war
memorial of the colonial New Zealand period.
Opened in 1908 it was created as a lasting reminder of the contribution of Southland's war dead
from the Boer War in 1900 to 1902.
The memorial was the first for the relatively new city of Invercargill.
While only 24 names are present on the Troopers' Memorial,
they represent those killed during or from the Boer War.
Southland sent a contingent of 273 men of its population of roughly 22,000.
This contingent, the fourth contingent, would be known as the rough riders
as they were all largely civilian
soldiers with little to no training.
The Troopers' Memorial stands as a
permanent reminder of new Zealand's role
in the Boer War and particularly those
Southland soldiers killed in act of service.